[Music]
we're in the middle of Passover the
holiday that celebrates the freedom of
the Jewish people from their bondage in
Egypt and I thought of an amazing way to
join in the celebration it's time ladies
and gentlemen for our first annual
throwing of a pharaoh through a giant
wall of matzah bring it out boys
[Applause]
of matzah those are hard to come by okay
but okay yes that's a wall of matzah but
where are you gonna find a pharaoh I
don't know I thought we'd just look in
the audience and sometimes I'm just I'm
just here to see the show yeah I got a
ticket like everybody else guy bring him
down just security
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now guys the permits was over okay
let's do this Pharaoh are you going to
let my people go I'm not a pharaoh I I
work at an egyptian restaurant no no
I'll I'll ask you one more time are you
going to let my people go I'm Catholic I
live in Chicago okay drum roll please
[Applause]
great show for lazy that have been
starved the Netflix original series
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt le campers
here
[Applause]
the fusion series that Chris Gethard
show Chris Gethard
[Applause]
make Maya's gonna be with us
[Applause]
you